Special Counsel
Jack Smith's investigation
into classified documents
at former presidents,
President Trump's Mar a Lago resort.
CNN has learned that a key
attorney is leaving Trump's legal team.
Caitlyn, this is your reporting
first on CNN.
What can you tell us?
Who is it?
Paul Harvey never told Tim Pawlenty,
who has been an attorney
at the center of the Mar
a Lago documents investigation.
Is leaving Trump's legal team.
It's been rumored for a few weeks now.
It became official yesterday.
We are told
he gave us a statement
saying that it was it,
that it was a personal decision
he's making
that it wasn't
an indication
of where he thinks
this investigation is going.
Of course,
we don't ultimately know what Jack
Schmidt, the special counsel
who's investigating
this, is going to decide
I think it's easy for you all to say,
you know,
there are a lot of Trump attorneys.
Which one is this?
This is partly to me.
He was the one who helped organize
those additional searches
that they did
for more documents
and other Trump properties
where they went and looked for them.
He testified
before the grand jury
that's investigating the documents
back in December.
He was there for several hours.
And one key thing
he said in March,
it was reported that he had gone.
He said they kept trying
to ask him about conversations
he had with Trump, clearly
trying to get to Trump's mindset.
He's an attorney.
He I think he said that at the time.
He did not speak to them about that.
One thing I will note,
though, is this comes
as he had defended
the way that Trump had handled
the documents, made this comment
in a case
where they have to prove willful
retention of documents.
What the facts actually
show is a persistent pattern
of willful return of marked documents
whenever they were found.
And so I went through all
that with the jury.
So that was his grand jury testimony.
The other thing that I think
is important here,
there is always infighting
in almost every legal team.
Trump has had,
I think, dating back to
when he entered the White House,
as long as
we've been covering his legal teams
There has also been that in
this legal team, not just on documents,
but there's so many different attorneys.
Joe Tacopina is the one
that you've seen representing Trump
in the aging Carol
case here in New York where he was found
civilly liable for sexual abuse.
I had Tim Pawlenty on.
I was interviewing him a few weeks ago,
maybe two months ago or so, and we asked
whether or not
he thought Tacopina was the right person
to take that case to trial.
He had a really telling answer.
This is what he said.
As to who's going to try the case.
I know that Joe has certain
potential conflict issues
given his prior contacts
with Stormy Daniels so,
you know,
who is the right attorney to take a trial
is something that
the client will have to decide
Yeah, that didn't go over well.
I think the other thing to consider here
is that
Trump has been very unhappy
with all the investigations
into him privately
especially the documents investigation,
because he's paid
a lot of attorneys, a lot of money.
And he's been asking people privately,
privately, you know,
why is this still going on?
Why hasn't had gone away yet?
Obviously, it's a very complicated case.
We don't know where it will end up.
But it is notable that Tim Pawlenty
is leaving his legal team.
He was on that case and testified
before the grand jury.
Let's talk
more about this news that Caitlyn broke
with our political director,
David Chalian,
also the host of the CNN
Political Briefing podcast.
What's your take, David?
Well, first of
all, it's
always an awkward thing
when you are the legal representation
and also a witness in the case
that has to testify
that that creates problems.
From the get go there.
But as Caitlin noted,
infighting in Trump's
legal circles is nothing new here.
So whenever we see
a Trump
legal team formed,
we can pretty much assume
that's not going to be
the team in place
when the case comes to resolution here.
You know, this classified documents case,
especially the potential for
and obstruction of justice charge here
is one of the most serious investigations
that the former president is facing.
So it's not a great day
when you have to shake up your legal team
for the client
if indeed it is
as serious as a case
as we believe this to be.
Yeah, we'll see what happens there.